And also record the think
they want two sessions. So
your consent form will count
for the sessions. Anyone knows
that the meeting is being
recorded.
Does somebody want to share
so that Shannon doesn't have
to go take minutes and
share? I can do it,
but it might be easier
unless it's a lot to
talk about. Sometimes I get
caught up.
Yeah, I think I think
it's a lot to ask.
Those me. How do you
feel about sharing?
But now I'm all because
I'm being recorded in.
You do webinars. Like I
don't got representation from
Brazil Nigeria have been good.
I think we could get
going to know if Karen
are valid or joining or
tune. Are you are our
client representative today? They, they
is going to get the
update. All right? But let
us get started. Then we'll
start with our country team
updates. So maybe I don't
know if I can hand
it over to you first
for Bangladesh.
Sure, so I can give
you a quick update on
the wild side as well
there. So we're making some
progress on reaching out to
eat with the policymakers. We
already have a couple of
interviews from working on a
few more interviews debate. I
think the only catch the
only thing that we are
struggling with his Service rates.
So I pay his head
like that.
If and maybe write a
write up paper on the
bar, other researchers working with
the data set. Exactly. I
think this is something that
we have to stop Pottery,
teacher May well, I believe
a lot of data
Download Zedge.
Yes, I am. Ajan that
the they'll be a lot
of work happening. Even after
the, the grant is finished
on the disseminating, the writing
up in disseminating results. And
so, thanks any questions or
comments for your toenail?
I was going to say,
I saw a couple questions
on slack from Val about
like making the data available
and Open Access then like
how long the gates will
pay Gates. Foundation will pay
for open-access article fees and
I don't know. I was
trying to look it up,
I can find anything specific
in RI
In a contract when we
will pay.
So A Hallelujah paper, but
I'll look into that. So,
we can know when know
that the data could be
made available online by the
end of August at the
latest. Does that sound right?
Yeah, that's what.
Just a quick thing to
remind you of a tunnel
is and if you can
remind Karen and Val, please
about the bereaved for Nigeria
and Kenya with the data
with the quantitative to email.
But if I was, if
you can remind them as
well, we do need to
get that those not going
to help the dissemination activities.
Are you in or are
already in touch with them
about the dissemination activities that
we discussed before or have
you about creating a brief
one for Nigeria and one
for Kenya on the quantitative
SOA? Me and and and
can use it in there
just a minute electricity.
So, thank you.
And that was sufficient. We
did both the Bangladesh and
the client team and can
I just add one thing
on the 2nd which was
a Nar Nar which was
the mixed message. One on
house in Kenya and Nigeria
and Amy M M N
O P Q R S
K on the cold stuff
so I was going to
school with
I hope you get to
go back now. I think
it's too late, right? I
think it's
Ready to be on Friday?
I'm working on it right
now. I think I would
be able to send it
back by tonight.
Any other questions or comments
for a tunnel?
It's not maybe we can
move on to Bruno. Mariela
from Brazil.
So we submitted a paper
about food insecurity, we are
still writing a paper on
women in rural communities, in
the lack of water and
a paper about the memories
of health professionals.
We are planning to do
a bridge on sexual and
reproductive health and about young
women and black activists Messer.
Ford poverty not much for
a predictable and also with
a black woman's Actavis.
yeah, that's
thanks brunette. And I do
need to follow up again
with Denise and I will
about the our meeting to
discuss policy engagement. So we
will be, I will be
in touch with that about
that.
Great. Any questions or comments
for Bruna?
When do you think you
might have a draft of
the breeze? Do you have
a deadline?
Know that it's a good
idea to have a deadline.
If you wanted to sign
Dan everything not have just
everything in the last week,
so we cannot see, have
some time to eat at
about it as well.
Stay with both. The researchers
that will do this to
breathe and instead with a
deadline with them.
Great. Thank you.
So moving on Nana to
Amy over to you.
Thanks Rose man. Good afternoon
everyone updates on the Nigerian
team. Last week, we had
a meeting with Yvette Rosemary
and brainstorm on Halloween can
disseminate finding that we've had
high levels of the federal
and state
So what is pushing ahead
with its own weight at
the valley with government and
Island you partner? Unfortunately or
maybe even that wasn't guaranteed.
They also could report income
Disseminating among their Crunchies. So
that's another thing that came
out of a brainstorming was
don't make it Monday covid
related. Make it much more
louder. So I supposed to
call Fitness 19 in the
out country. Romantic movies has
taken the back seat for
many things, so make it
look for more organizations to
help watch to do a
little bit of research. We've
also identified that we want
to have another organization that
walked around
Give me the field for
the stick holder. So we're
currently around in that concept
to share with you Sunday
and also with rosemary and
everyone else. The target date
is June the looking at
June 15 or 16 based
on agreement and that will
help us walk backwards. Make
sure everything is in place
for 25 presents and just
basically high-level where we have
a cold.
I'll report it to be
at the end of June,
we're hoping that we would
finalize to brief. So one
brief is an informal women
and their experiences informal Market.
Women on the experiences during
covid-19 health care workers and
their experiences as well. Have
pulled the stop talking and
the hard copy because we
love hard copies of everything,
so that the government officials.
Come give him a pass.
We also had reached out
to Valerie and Karen.
Because we want to incorporate
with the quantitative and qualitative
findings in the presentation. So
that's why we act in
that email about your findings
on the 3rd birthday Rosemary.
I just a friendly reminder.
And any other documentation that
would have said, would have
to be in a hard
copies. And every other thing
that has come out of
Nigeria last update from my
team and I are happy
to hear you're coming and
you might as well do
something about the extended Network.
We did do something but
it seems really can't see.
So I'm still having to
add to it. So that's
why I haven't sent it.
I will send it before
the end of the month,
fingers crossed and everything crossed.
Any questions or comments for
Amy?
Besides, that's a lot of
good job.
I will take that to
be honest with what I'm
going to do. I will
take that. So yeah, bring
it on ghost.
I'm excited about the vent,
you should be Rosemary and
I'm doing this for you
very little work.
Okay you can come over
there. Nobody don't worry guys.
Last week. If it's true
that the gates are unable
to you don't publicize advances
to. They have too many
grantees and they can't really,
you know, bring up expectations
and do it for other
guy and cheese. However, if
we do want to publicize
use their name, in our
pubs, on our advertising, there
is a process to go
through and it usually takes
about three weeks. I have,
I saved the link somewhere
that event scared but you
just submit their the event.
This I think it's the
same with a if with
publication things that you want
to use their name on
and it will go through
internal processes. So Amy I
was thinking we could do
that but we would want
to make sure we do
it in enough time.
Yes, yes. Okay, so what
I would spend the day
and then we can talk
about how that looks like,
right. I know that you
had put your link and
there's a whole phone to
feel so yeah. I think
I saved it on my
computer, the link. So let's
have the concept that I
can put in the request
for that. Happy to do
that.
Any other questions or comments?
Great. And I'm moving on
to Kenya grave site. Are
you here on behalf of
and for Kenya?
Are you are? And my
daughter was using it will
help. I will study session
and I cannot change it.
Which is me. I was
like, who is Greg? Changing
it but I don't know
why it's not working but
nonetheless, it speak in Kenya.
It's good to hear from
you. Also the updates that
you have from Kenya to
papers are in progress. The
faster is the impact of
school closure on adolescent girls
and schooling adolescent girls that
when we're doing it. So
we are writing it's purely
quality with us to data
PhD student from
A musically without one focusing
on the Kenyan. Rita the
second one is one way
that I mentioned in the
last meeting.
Community Health volume, but not
just on their service provision
during covid, better and Supply
agenda analysis. Fremont, Regency on
the double rule out there,
playing and service providers and
women in the community for
copy defect that I don't
know how that's going to
work out. But I'm Savage
Health Service provision during concerts
of the unicorn of this
one to be for CHD,
has parents Mother's wives and
also have his provide does
Howell public affection.
Just over the conceptual stage.
We are we are reaching
out to say that was
easy because it was in
the impact on school closures.
In production has been done
in the methodology. So for
both, we're doing and
Beyond the introduction. You're trying
to look at the narratives
and see what that don't
make sense to fit into
that place for evidence. Download,
I just submitted the final
version of the sgpc, one
sexual violence, experiences of adolescent,
girls, and young women to
Kate for the final design.
Also, have one for mental
health, that we are doing
an h u a w
on vaccine that was on
the planet. That's what you
discuss your going to produce
an event for the writing
workshop and access to education
during emergency.
Even though this download Eric,
I know that there's some
papers but I still in
progress. So my my preference
would be relevant. I don't
know what I can gather
that information go into a
paper, so some of the
narratives are the Colts have
directions to find a General
on it. I can just
produce the evidence to download
and pretty much have the
same data in the journal
as well. But those are
the ones that we're doing
right now until health.
Betting line on boxing app,
ticket hesitant or hesitancy. And
another education access to education
for school and girls, doing
the emergency TV show podcast,
way back when I was
able to present same-day tone
s g busy and access
to healthcare. One, is being
hosted by Steve Thomas University
in Florida. So that just
about to release top podcasts,
I needed to know how
it is that. I mentioned
that the box I present
said was from this Jenna
covid project. So I know
I think I think there's
an email sent from the
disclaimer. So go back and
look at it. They have
to put a narrative and
also volunteered our platform to
share this photo Sun City
as big data on on
HGTV on this brands of
soda, gender covered.
Website abused as a platform
for its dissemination.
I didn't receive the the
kind of policy brief. We're
still discussing it internally because
it involves so many sectors
on which is the best
approach to do it, whether
you like a webinar in
Kenya, Bellevue city and advice
to all those players or
Target a specific technical working
groups. Even our own communication
offers the best approach for
each other. We will host
a webinar and invite all
those players are we go
out to them in the
specifics. So I'm sorry, I
have to know what time
back to you on that
because of me, not being
very clear, the best bicycle
by the end of this
week, by Skype on it.
Yeah, that's that's plastic for
my Sylvia. We we've done
and what we have available
quotes available data, see if
anybody wants to include an
equally data on Kenya and
mistress and I'm just an
email away, I'll be able
to put that narrative together
very quickly and she had
to go to pick up
for Claire's and time use
paper.
The conversation on Karen's a
mental health, professional whether to
change it into a mixed
method and we have coats
on that. Since I'm doing
the evidence, download for it.
Thank you. And yeah, lots
of lots of lots of
stuff going on and lots
of dissemination activities such as
great with the, with the
Kenya brief, it may not
remember, that's the 35, and
how can you responded to
the pandemic with a gender
lens that both Alice and
hungry really? So it's been
prepared and drafted. I'm pretty
much almost ready to go
and and we will absolutely
take your lead on. I'm
thinking about what's best to
way to disseminate that and
if we can support you
in any way, let us
know Kate, I might hand
it over to you about
the the comment or the
question about briefs vs. Papers.
If I can.
Yeah. Sorry I was just
spinning in the spreadsheet without
a productivity. You know how
paper is available and they
play different roles tonight. I
just think that you, you've
contributed one free so and
I really think and Catholic
at the tropics that and
how you want to spend
your time getting that it's
limited is an important thing
to do. So you thinking
of doing the mental health,
one as well.
Oh, you're muted.
Yes, mental health. And did
you ate a biscuit with
an impact of coffee that?
I don't enjoy W's, Mental
Health, and Social well-being. So
that these are the narratives
that dances just filling in
the blanks of the introduction
and get that the generic
form it into the canyon
or something equally in Ozone
vaccine, uptake can hesitancy and
access to education and which
one of those topics would
rather put in a paper
than a bridge.
I saw I saw the
ones from the from the
Excel on Publications, was a
paper on Kenya or had
Canyon dates on box it
up someone leaving and I'm
not hundred percent sure, but
I don't see the harm
in having both parts papers.
I think I can I
catch up with you? I'm
more than happy to.
Transform this evidence downloads in
two papers. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Of course. So I guess
that it's a question for
the qualitative research is I'm
not sure how the topics
of the papers are prioritized.
And yeah, I seen the
list of them but I
don't know the process, I
guess. Yeah. So can I
just, I think I do
in terms of the paper
that's being, I think the
Quan team is working on
it on vaccine uptake. Now
I believe and probably in
process is probably not an
opportunity to feed the qualitative
data into that. I'm speaking
for Karen and Val so
I don't know if I'm
sure but they are. I'm
at I think it's a
the paper so it probably
isn't possible to feed the
koala into that but on
to know correct me if
I'm wrong.
Yeah, I think of brexit
up their fur is what
I wanted to do. Something
for mental health, stress anxiety.
I think for those topics
we naturally think that their
scopes for or mixed method
approach, the one that you
need a license to Quality
Extrusion maybe maybe.
So hit me up lyrics.
I need.
Good to hear you. I
think now that we've got
all the data from almost
the data from all day
qualitative work as well as
the third rat 3-valve Squad,
that's probably don't know. Maybe
one thing we need to
think about is having just
a research meeting with teams
to discuss these opportunities to
collaborate and bring the data
together. But and I want
to say also and I
see a comment here
About some others about what's
been done with the breeze
in the papers. And I
know I've done that, she
was my own researches that
I wrote in a brief
first and then turned it
into a paper and you
can use the same guy.
Like I said, two different
outfits in the paper, the
academic paper will be so
much more about that you
can use the same data
and both so, but yeah.
I think I might be
a good idea to start
with what you what's most
exciting and interesting to you
escape that and do the
briefs men, develop those papers.
Yeah, thank you. Yeah, maybe
a research output to submit
nations, are the paper type
meeting would be a really
nice idea because we can
also supports that as well
as to your come in
a me about about papers,
we can help support you
you know, to to do
some of that work as
well. So I think with
with a and you can
see a lot, a lot
of people started with briefs
and turn those into papers.
That's a nice way to
do it. They are very
different outputs, they serve different
purposes. And as I mentioned,
reach different audiences. I said
I don't see nothing wrong
with having them and it
says, Kate mentioned at this
really you have limited time.
So what do you want
to put your efforts on?
What are the topics that
you really want to get
out? And then also thinking
about the dissemination event or
events, so you'll be having
between now and and June,
what would be most helpful
at those events as well
and terms of output. So
those are the kind of
decision
Can make.
In regards to those things.
Okay. Any other questions or
comments for an
No, we had the quantitative
update so I don't know
if Claire do we have?
You have anything extra on
the qualitative side, the last
night instead, I don't know
any. I don't think you
mentioned that Amy and Alice
at the palace has been
working on it paper. With
some of you with qualitative
findings from Nigeria, that I
think Alice is going to
be revising, everyone's comments now
and then hopefully will be
submitted soon. The only thing
I just say which is
directly related to qualitative, but
everybody is a reminder about
the gates open access policy
cuz you're just talking about
that and I did look
it up and if you
everyone should be, make sure
they double-check this document before
they submit and they go
through all those steps in
that does included in that
funding statement to include with
your publication.
So and I'll put some
slack as well. Just a
reminder to everyone to keep
that in mind.
I think that's all I
have.
I think Julia I think
was an eval asking about
how long that will? That's
the open-access the gates will
pay for open-access after the
finishes think that's something. We
also need to look into.
Yeah, that's why I try.
I try to figure that
out and I haven't seen
any like time limit on
it, so I look more
carefully cuz I just got
this morning with you for
this meeting. Oh, and get
back to everyone, LOL. Chaska
bat.
Thank you.
So, moving on and our
agenda than any of that.
Qualitative side, Claire. Did you
have anything else you want
me to bring in?
Play nothing to me.
All right, so our Communications
and tools update. So we
do we meet bi-weekly as
a team to go over
all of the different outfits
that everyone is creating. Thanks
Kate. I was going to
do that. If you need
to it. Good. Good minds
think alike. We have a
spreadsheet that sort of keeps
track and then it looked
at Kate was updating it
as we were speaking. So
thanks so much. Maybe Kate.
If I can maybe get
hand it over to you
to go over any of
the pertinent points here.
I'm happy to do it
as well though.
That thing where you can
unmute when you said let
me try again. Yeah I
could see you in the
face in the document at
the same time is that
flight like the rest of
you as the adult to
coordinate so we tried to
put together this track and
chair takes us through different
types of output some activities
and 5/8 against them expensive.
Well, we've got to hit
them. So for June, 6th,
10 to process, the evidence.
Download from Bangladesh on sr876,
we're still awaiting a draft
of the month.
We're also have another app
to download on increased spending
on women with size, come
into town, and sent back
and on the way to
the next door, final draft.
In April. And I Brittany,
just told us, they have
a couple of evidence downloads.
They want to produce, Julia
is producer, Julian colleagues are
producing a brief on the
food and accommodation set to
in Canada. And then in
Kenya, perhaps we all have
mental health at Bree from
on, but to have some
other topics, we just waiting
to see what seems best.
We have a brief, that's
gone for design on trust
and they all say that
once in French, but we
are expecting an English version
of the translation. I don't
know if there's any update
on that.
I reached out to somebody
about that but I haven't
heard back from them yet.
She sent the final version
of a brace on gbv
and I sent that for
design and Amy mentioned, if
you breach, that they would
doing, we haven't had the
first draft of those yet,
but look at them saying,
I'm sure I don't know
whether I m going to
do all of these, cuz
this folder.
But we can discuss.
What is 3? Sorry, Leann
has the disk repair pesta,
a paper on race and
gender and healthcare workers, which
has now been designed as
Netflix download. And then as
mentioned area, we are hoping
to have some briefs of
some kind on the court
date. So low, we haven't
received anything as yet but
I know that a man
of them have no communication
book themes or questions. That
would be good for that
contacts at 2 to talk
to.
Done in terms of known
as download kind of briefs
and responsive. Pandemic planning document
is quite long from Kenya
has been sent to design.
A design is finished and
we'll start communicating it next
week. Eric has written a
really excellent brief on suits
food. Insecurity of food security
which is being sent around
4, at the moment. Epithets
very near to final of
the prime rate of covid-19.
And we have in this
planet, the book chapters that
we agreed to do but
not quite sure where the
book is this point. And
then we just that the
weapon has so much with
possibly going to have an
event on Kenya.
In April, the work to
group is hoping to hold
a weapon on that call
to action which is an
output of the two-day conference
that they did earlier in
the year. And then in
June were hoping to have
some kind of end of
project conference where we bring
together, all that we've learned.
And for this, My Collie
Kylie and I are kind
of writing a report that
sums up what we've learned
what we done in Pat's
about, whatever the time we've
been working. And I think
I did send some slides.
So you'll come to stations
with the bat. Then take
the shown in the end,
but that gives you a
sense of like come from
the tracker, how we got
to affect things, have been
going since security webinar, so
that what is scheduled for
May 10th?
Bruna Anna to know. So
Erica will be moderating and
we've got Bruno tono and
someone from standing together for
nutrition and wanted to reach
out to a discuss. And
so we've got a date
for that. I'm setting up
a pay. You no registration
page. It will be able
to start advertising for that
in April. Yeah, thanks bro.
Sometimes, you know, I have
an account from the wiccan
groups. So the school to
action has been sent for
design, it says an intersectionality
reckoner coming from manasi, whatever.
Maybe we put the concept
paper for extra from being
here, cuz you did some
work on that as well.
And then you heard about
the plans for the policy
making me seem. So I
won't go through that again,
but that will soon have
you noticed if there's any
way that we can assist
in communication to do you
ask him will help out.
Don't know if there's any
questions or anything else back
of that.
Don't see anyone coming up.
I guess what I would
say it's like you know
into the design is going
to be doing a lot
of work from here on
the end up until June
basically. So if you if
you believe that there's something
coming up that you might
need a helpful as to
tell us sooner rather than
later. So we can try
and make time for everything
and at the moment, we
try to make it. So
my cousin comes at the
same time as if everything
comes in June and we
won't have much time to
communicate
Great.
Thanks so much. Thanks so
much for that update, so
you haven't got lots, lots
of stuff going on. As
Kate mentioned, do reach out.
Let us know if we
could support on anything in
particular Phillips move on. We
just have a couple more
items on our agenda. Quick.
A debrief of last week's
meeting with Evette. I guess
it's just a quick summary
of that is met with
event. We Julia presented some
updates on the results tracker
and our output related to
that. And then we had
a brief presentation event asked
us to prevent overarching. Some
key findings and messages and
we put together a presentation,
very high-level themes. And every
day we had representations on
a different country teams and
that that presented that and
we just really had a
discussion it over to you.
But if debriefing, we didn't
have time we had a
lot of other stuff on
the agenda and then get
time to do it. Like
I wanted to go over
other impact that we've had
including the presentation that Kaden
team put together and there
was something else I wanted
to go over, but didn't
get a chance but we
did send all the material
to that after
Yeah, I think I'm one
lesson. I learned that meeting
as we need to be
more realistic about her agendas.
It was just way too
much, but that's fine. Yeah,
I guess, I just wanted
to open app to see
if anyone else who was
there. Had any Reflections or
comments? As well as if
anybody wasn't there. I had
any questions. I think that
overarching message I got from
from the meeting was that
the foundation would give that
is like willing says she
is she's a kind of
advocate for her project to
get him continuation of it
but she doesn't want to
raise her hopes up. If
it's Stephanie by no means
a sure thing as an
ongoing conversation and she also
made a comment about to
have my take out of
a bit more time due
to changes in the foundation
and everything. So that was
just kind of My overall
impression is that this is
the conversation will continue but
she is definitely not
How to know, which direction
will go yet? I have
any questions or reflections?
What's with all the time?
She hasn't given any feedback
on the items that we
sent her know, I haven't
heard about it because he's
at it, some questions on
the results track and so
on, and I haven't heard
back that I did offer
to meet with her. Like
I said, I guess it's
easier to have a conversation
about it and her to
write an email, whatever I'm
going to have another call.
When's the next meeting with
her Shannon, is it next
month or in two months
time?
I'm actually not, I'm actually
not sure. I'll have to
check the schedule if it's
still monthly, or if it's
something, you might not know
who OT is not next
month. We might want to
suggest to meet again next
month. So he has every
two months, because the next
one that I have is,
May 17th, which is, basically
the end. So, maybe if
we want one in April,
will have to request that.
Everybody know when that meeting
is in case like a
country leads want to attend.
I know, it's really hard
with everyone's schedules and time
difference, but I think it's
good to create opportunity. The
country needs one as well.
Yeah, we didn't have a
huge amount of time to
discuss the concept that we
sent, but she thanked us
for sending it and said
that she will share it
as well and in the
foundation and will advocate for
us. She did mention that
she was very impressed about
all that the all the
activities we've been doing in
the impact that we've had
been able to have and
it does sound like the
foundation is going through some
restructuring and that's ongoing and
how this project would fit
into that and if it
would we don't know. So
it right now, it's all
up in the air. Just
have to wait and see
what they come back when
she comes back with.
Any other comments questions reflections?
Okay, so Financial in output
reporting's. Julia Shannon.
So, you had asked that
we can pile results today
which I did with lots
of analysis, help, and it
was actually a pretty good
exercise cuz it showed that
where is a few bits
and pieces left to do.
If I just want to
remind everyone that we have
to submit our final report
to the Gates Foundation by
the end of June. So
I think that your next
quarterly report is actually due
in June, but instead, I'd
like to request a day,
you submit everything by the
end of May. So I
have time to do that.
Vinyl record and share it
with everybody and get feedback.
And I wasn't really want
to emphasize reporting around interactions
with decision-makers and policy impact.
If you look at the
monthly reports which allowed Dropbox,
those blocks are always empty.
People don't put anything in
them. And when I followed
up with some of you
like one-on-one, a lot of
you have had
data that can go in
there. I know it's cuz
it's the type of thing
that doesn't come to mind.
And you don't always like
He's not like a paper,
a great Friday and every
time you have a conversation
or an email or attend
a meeting, you don't write
it down. So we all
forget these things but it
is important that we capture
everything that we've done and
all the interactions and I've
been had. So I just
really encourage you to think
about that if when you
put together that final report
of anything, throw the project
where you've had an interaction
with a policymaker, a decision
maker had a conversation with
them and can include Civil
Society, doesn't just have to
be government. If you've had
a conversation, if you had
an email exchange, if I
asked you anything about the
project, let's capture that. And
if it's if you're not
sure if it's my 11th
or not put it in
and then we can sort
it out afterwards. So just
wanted to emphasize that cuz
I think that's the one
area that we need to
beef up and the foundation's
right interested in and I
think everybody is doing, but
maybe not quite realizing that
are doing it.
So yeah. So please I
mean, I know when March
now so the enemy is
not far from now. But
please please, I'm going to
beg you and harass you
to get a report by
the end of May so
that I can do that
final avoid and we can
have time to reflect on
it.
And Shannon is going to
make us or Amy. Go
ahead.
Do we have to come
in by the end of
May? What happens to events
in June? Does it get
Regina? Nor do we do
we say we're doing it
planned? Say that you would
say it's planned for June
and if it happens in
June and it hasn't been
planned, you know, let me
know when it does happen
and we'll put it in
as we go. I'm in
Eden things after that, Riley
keeps keep it, though. It
back out of it. I
just want to be able
to get at least most
of their work done. So
I'm not like, you know,
riding a final report on
the evening of June 30th
or something. I think I
got it.
I think Santa has a
similar plea around financial reporting.
Yeah, I was just going
to comment first on Amy's
question. There is that we
can always submit it to
Gates and then if they
ask us for
Anything for their reporting or
they want clarification. We can
always add in anything after
us like an addendum to
the reporting. So just better
that we keep track of
all that even if it
happens after the end of
the deadline,
Just in case they come
back and stay one more
clarification or want more information,
and then regarding its financial
reporting. The same thing is
that
If it's SSU does not
get an extension to the
grant, which we probably won't,
then we cannot extend the
sub grounds. So that means
all of your spending has
to happen before the end
of the grant. So you
have to, if you haven't
spent your money yet, you
have to spend it save
all your documentation send us
the invoices, because sfsu does
not get an extension which
for not going to request
one, we cannot give you
an extension to spend your
money so we don't want
to leave anything on the
table. So just make sure
that your financial records are
up-to-date and that whoever in
your institution you need to
speak with to make sure
that you get all those
records submitted to me do
that as soon as possible
and just get that sorted
because it does take time
as well. And yes, we
are coming up to the
beginning of April.
Yeah, just a quick thing
on the tools and communication
side and also looks like
we won't be able to
form at any briefs after
2 so or anything. So
that. So I did look,
you know, a lot of
people had evidence briefs in
the planning, you know. That's,
that's a lot. We need
time to be able to
do that. You'll have a
better idea of the timing,
but I would say we
wouldn't want to get any
briefs later than the end
of the end of May.
Correct. That's my preference. None
of your going to stick
to that but I would
say like the second week
of June is the absolute
call Queen absolute.
yeah, so that, you know,
as you're doing your evidence
downloads and briefs just keep
that in mind that the
earlier the better, but the
second week of June, we
cannot accept it after that
cuz we won't be able
to pay for the other
services, so please do to
keep that in mind when
you're planning your
Any questions or comments about
financial and output reporting?
Nope. Okay, so the last
item is any other business.
Did anyone want to raise
anything that we hadn't chatted
about?
I guess on our side
we are going to be
her only three months away,
it's going to come so
fast. We will need to
be, will start planning or
June event, whatever that's going
to be. You heard Kate
and Healy already really thinking
about it. We would like
all countries to be represented
in that event. So we
don't we don't know what
it's going to look like
yet but we probably do
need to get started on
thinking about it. We're organizing
our food, insecurity brief we're
going to be thinking we
want to do the Kenya.
However the Kenya event will
be for that for the
prefix, take your lead on
that and I'll wait for
your email. If you want
it to be just Kenya
or more Global and then
we'll have that final webinar
and that's probably our capacity
on an event that will
support any internal events that
are happening. You know what?
Engagement activities, absolutely.
But yeah, so it will
be in touch about that
at final event and maybe
we'll put it. Maybe we'll
have to put some extra
time on next. Month's meeting
to discuss it and that
will make sure that we
went we we come more
prepared or with a little
bit more thinking around that.
Okay, if there's nothing else,
we can wrap up a
4 minutes early.
He said he went thanks
for cheering Rosemary, get this
right on schedule. Yeah, we
got through a lot today.
Thanks everyone.